Hey guys, it's grant jumping in to remind you
There's still one week left to win this galaxy s 9 plus smart phone. It could be yours
There's a link down in the description to get your name on the list to qualify. Best of luck. We'll see you around
Hey guys. I am Nate. We are at the dome once again with another experiment using molten salt
We're going to see what happens. If you combine molten salt with eggs in a couple of different ways
We'll see what happens if we pour a molten salt on to an egg
We'll probably try dropping a whole egg into
our crucible full of molten salt and then I think we'll try pouring some molten salt onto our frying pan and then see if we
Can fry an egg on that salt we have all of our equipment and supplies and eggs. Let's fire up the furnace
Our salt is just about melted so let's put some eggs into our little pot here. I'm gonna try something a little odd
I'm gonna try having two cracked eggs and two whole eggs
And I'm just gonna pour the salt on top and that way we'll be able to see the effect on both of those at once
Ready? Three, two, one. Whoo!
Something cracked immediately. I'm not sure what that was
Just right as I poured it into the pot something made a cracking noise and I assume
That was something from the moisture in the eggs themselves
Tell you what, that does not smell really great; that egg shell is still in place. This egg shell is partially not in place
It’s not exactly cooked thoroughly
But it’s still very hot. So of course things could still be cooking in there. In fact this part of the shell opened
Still ucooked inside there...try and dump the whole thing out salt and eggs onto our frying pan here
That worked pretty good. So we've got all of our salt right here we've got some
I'm gonna say overcooked egg right here. This part it looks like we've got some
fairly nicely cooked egg
mixed with raw egg
Well, let's move on to the next thing
All right
We're gonna drop an egg into the molten salt in the crucible and quickly back away because I don't know what's gonna happen
Three, two, one
Wow!
Let's do another one. Three, two, one
I guess it did cool down a little bit. Oh that smells so bad
There’s our egg already partially cooked through
The first egg exploded violently the second egg, not so much
So our egg shell kind of got coated in some of the melted salt
Definitely stuck to it a little bit. It's kind of gross. So this is the shell with the salt stuck to it
This is the actual egg which burned in parts and is raw in parts. I’m just gonna squish it
It's a step
Beyond eggs over it easy right there
So now I've got a final batch of salt heating up in the furnace I'm gonna pour that
Right on to our frying pan and then I'm gonna try and crack an egg onto that and see if I can cook the egg
Get a nice fried egg, maybe even try and flip it over in the pan
That looks so frickin’ awesome
Glowing orange liquid. All right, let's let that salt cool down just a bit because I'm not trying to destroy these eggs
I do want a hot surface, but I want to actually cook them and
Possibly eat one. So I think as long as it's still glowing orange. It's probably too hot
I'm going to try cracking one right there some get a good spot
Got space for one more
Well, it is spilling off the side a little bit but we've got some nice cooked looking egg at the bottom
I'm just not sure if there will be enough heat to cook all the way through
for me to try and
Really get this thing cooked. I also don't know anything about the nonstick properties of salt. So this could be
Very stuck or not at all stuck
Actually seems to come off pretty easily
Not holding itself together very well though
I don’t know if that piece is hot so it might not be doing anything to cook it it might just be resting on it
This is definitely starting to get cooked through/though
Let's see if I can flip this egg over. I don't think I'll be able to smoothly get under it
So it's gonna get a little torn up as I try
Mmm my salt might be cooling down a little too much
This one is just completely fallen apart. So I don't think I can really flip anything
That yolk isn't even a little bit cooked
when this portion of the egg
Looks like it has cooked. Not really a good-looking cooked egg, but it's something
Cheers!
Basically fried egg actually pretty good
Very salty, I might have added too much salt because it might have already been salted
Didn't really test that. Let’s try a bit that I didn’t get much salt on
I think it did. I think it picked up some of the salt
Using molten salt to cook eggs in a few different varieties
We tried pouring molten salt into a pot that had some cracked eggs and some uncracked eggs in it something
Cracked the moment I poured the salt into that. I'm not sure what that was
Maybe just one of the shells breaking open
Maybe that was some steam forming harder to really tell. I really liked the look of the glowing orange molten salt surrounding the eggs
That was pretty freaking cool. We then tried dropping a whole egg into our crucible full of molten salt
and the first one we did I
Dropped it in and immediately it exploded and kind of went flying out of the crucible. That was also really cool
I dropped another egg into there after the first one popped out. It didn't pop
It didn't really crack much but it did just sit in there and burn quite a bit then
I tried pouring out the molten salt onto a frying pan and cracking a couple of eggs
on to the salt after it had solidified to try and cook the eggs right on the salt and
Overall, even this is best of the three methods for using salt to cook an egg. It's really not a good plan
You don't get anywhere very useful. If you've got any ideas of things that you want to see us do with molten salt
Let us know down in the comments and if we use your idea, we will send you 25 bucks
Hey, what's up guys is grant here with a brand new Galaxy S 9 plus smartphone that I'm giving away to one of you for
Subscriber appreciation. I've got a link down the description so you can get your name on the list and qualify to win